die kinder gehalten die kinder alles zu
locken
also irgendwie wartet man redet was geht
ab herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich geht
es gut mir auch danke viele sind immer
so nett und schreiben einen kommentar
oder danke dazu gefragt was mir geht es
soweit ganz gut ich hoffe du wirst auch
gut also ist er dann auch mal
beantwortet ich habe es im video das
gestern gab es schon gesagt ich war
sechs tage nicht in deutschland ich war
in skandinavien unterwegs und ich habe
viele instagram nachrichten bekommen
zu einem gewissen video von meinem guten
kollegen von letzte mal war ich möchte
ich so einen kram passt du musst dich du
weißt ist und möchte dass vier brille
ist alles gut zwischen uns so ist auf
der gamescom erscheint und zwar reden
wir von hier bio verbot besser man ich
habe mich auch instagram auch irgendwie
so ein bisschen mit dem unterhalten
wollte man muss ich kann ja mal kurz
zeigen ich habe mir nämlich lasst uns
auf irgendeinem video hier reagiert
ansagen alex wir wissen dass das kann
nicht mehr gegen ja das offline genommen
keine ahnung warum findet ja schade naja
immerhin habe ich darauf reagiert hier
die heftigste anlage geben mich war ganz
lustig und der hat mir daraufhin bei
instagram geschrieben weil ich habe so
am ende aus spaß gesagt dass ich ihnen
irgendwie anzeigen möchte weil er mich
so fragen also das war aber nur spaß als
wenn ich mir die mühe mache und ich habe
es natürlich auch mit humor genommen
servus hier ist bio habe und ich habe
eine frage du willst mich ja jetzt an
zeigen inwiefern meinst du das ernst
habe ich geschrieben alles gut mach dir
keinen kopf
dann ist ja gut übrigens bin ich schon
18 eigentlich bin ich nicht so der typ
aber durch ach so genau durch dich läuft
main kanal wieder danke gerne und dann
hat einmal geschrieben haye am montag
kommt ein diss track online du bist
unter anderem das drin bei interesse
höher ist je mehr an
und wir haben sehr sehr viele leute auf
insider geschrieben alex neuer disc
combo verbot das auch
uns geklingelt du wirst auch erwähnt
schauen dass auf jeden fall mal an und
ja deswegen sitze ich jetzt hier
ich bin ganz ganz gespannt ich habe
schon mal ganz leicht rein gehört wie
man sehen kann
und ja irgendjemand pizza bestellt war
nicht mal meine pizza aber ich musste
trotzdem die tür aufmachen alles klar
ich will eigentlich auch gar nicht lange
lagern und wir haben wir jetzt mal rein
ich bin wirklich gespannt ob das
einigermaßen gutes oder halt nicht wir
haben 85 likes 414 des lecks 211
kommentare das ist schon verdammt gut
gemacht 2600 aufruf und 211 kommentare
jeder zehnte hat kommentiert ich würde
aufpassen was du sagst seien nicht so
frech charmant ist für dich fetzen alle
haben kassen und dann kommst du zu mir
steht glaube ich noch nicht zu oder naja
gut 321
[Musik]
ich habe kein adblocker übrigens also
ich benutze was nicht ist super wichtig
um eine youtube kollegen zu unterstützen
deswegen würde ich euch auch empfehlen
applocker auszumachen einer werbung
anschauen das war gar kein problem bei
mir auch manchmal zweimal hintereinander
schade da muss ich noch mal kurz das war
für mich jetzt für mich so schnell
[Musik]
die masse der scorpion kommen wir am
anfang zu dir sonst wirst du sowieso
verlieren bei der musikalisch gesehen
bin ich ja nicht wirklich begabt aber
das war eine grausame rein also 69
videos oder deine art stand by me gelöst
ich muss nicht mehr bezahlen habe jetzt
habe ich das mit beziehung ist aus
viele youtube mit gleich so und mit
panzern beschossen verblendete kircher
nicht bis zum kriegsende ist aber ich
muss sagen es ist so so so ganz leicht
offbeat das hat das sagt man glaube ich
wenn die stimme nicht richtig auf dem
beat ist ja sagt also oft wie heißt ja
klar aber ich hätte es mir noch
schlechter vorgestellt um ehrlich zu
sein also ich war so voll das kam schon
am 14
das hat man heute den 21 das ist schon
eine woche online also es werden alle
youtuber gebiss wahrscheinlich die schon
mal irgendwie auf ihn reagiert haben ich
weiß jetzt sicher oder so schon mal auf
ihn reagiert hat oder sonst was machst
du es kopien das weiß ich so nie loops
keine ahnung und ich ja auch deswegen
komme ich wahrscheinlich jetzt auch
irgendwann bin ich mal gespannt was er
zu mir sagt
[Musik]
er wollte mal das haben wir überhaupt
nicht verstanden
das war doch jetzt das war an mich
gerichtet warte noch mal genauso wie
alex wie click bettdecke klar was war
was klick bettgitter blanche das ist das
sind wir ja noch nie gehört löschen
lassen
verletzende äußerungen war etwas
heiliges blasphemie nasschemie das ist
ein guter rein also da werde ich nicht
drauf gekommen blasphemie das war habe
ich ohne spaß das wort habe ich noch nie
in meinem leben gehört und ich habe
viele werden schon gehört aber jetzt
stellt sich natürlich die frage ob er
das auch wirklich meint genauso wie die
kinder
blasphemie nevada das ist ja blasphemie
und er sagt ja chemie das wort dann gibt
es das nicht oder du hast doch irgendwie
nicht richtig ausgesprochen wenn du
blasphemie mainz fordern die kinder
anzulocken
also irgendwie was die kinder die nachts
nutzen die kinder alle anzulocken und
sie danach abzuziehen
also ich habe noch nie in meinem ganzen
leben doch ich habe einmal so zwei merge
sachen verkauft aber mehr auch nicht
also um ehrlich zu sein ich weiß das
natürlich nicht ob da noch was kommt ich
hoffe es mal so das war es für mich noch
nichts so klick kannst du eigentlich zu
jedem sagen gegen ihre kitze abziehen
kann man auch zu vielen youtube ansagen
obwohl es so sagt das stimmt nicht mal
meine meinung nach niemand hat natürlich
gab es aber so extrem fälle aber ich
kann mich jetzt nicht daran erinnern
wann das letzte mal irgendeinen youtuber
offensichtlich kids abgezockt hat nun
diesen lauf
die sie einfach
die deutschen heute wo der hammer hängt
hier die lounge sowie color spenden
sage meine meinung bis mich jeder anni
tätig
[Musik]
warte mal ist das jetzt hier sei aber
jetzt will es aber ganz kriminell ihr
jetzt kommt die huk ok moment
[Musik]
heute machen zwar klein aber nicht und
draußen
man merkt was gezeigt wird
wiesbaden 54 der jurist
den finde ich ja zu recht gut also der
der hier sein feedback we try also
natürlich brauchen wir nicht über die
videoqualität und so sprechen aber auch
da ist jetzt also ein bisschen talent
verhalten für sowas muss man ganz klar
sagen das ist vielleicht hat er noch
kein eigenes team released alles gut
aber ich finde ich nicht schlecht also
energies das finde ich immer so das ist
das schlimmste was in einem musikvideo
passieren kann wenn so richtig krass die
lippen halt nicht synchron sind mit dem
was man sieht und dann auch noch wenn
man so ein auf gangster macht oder wenn
es so ein web-video ist da ist das ein
absolutes no-go wartet dann kommt halt
direkt zu voll für lächerlich über
obwohl es eigentlich genau das gegenteil
bewirken soll
und das ist halt hier gerade dabei die
leuchtdichte aber ich möchte es ist für
dich zu china als dem und in dem maße
einfach kopieren zugeht ist den kanal
keiner will die schenkel
sexy du hast eine vorbildfunktion hier
stattdessen durch die sich hinter dem
livestream hättest du bist nicht der
schlimmste aber peinlich der behälter
pro tours wasserreichtum ist schaue
allein für diese kriege wie du dich
selbst die schuld zu finden wir müssen
mal kurz pausieren
wir hatten jetzt rebecca will ein fand
ich ganz neues so exel gibt es macht den
youtube-videos habe ich ewig nichts von
gehört und ja okay ich habe gehört ja
olli ist im gefängnis gelandet ich weiß
nicht ob's stimmt aber man hat auf
vielen netzwerken nichts mehr von ihm
gehört vielleicht ist ein bisschen
untersuchungshaft kurz verweisen das bin
ich auch mit kindertagesstätte
vielleicht ist ja olio in der
kindertagesstätte und nicht im gefängnis
es kann natürlich auch sein
[Musik]
das finde ich jetzt ein bisschen schade
dass ich jetzt hier nur einmal ganz am
anfang erwähnt wurde dass ich klick
machen und die leute verarschen
bei bio verbot haben wir bei uns
geschrieben am montag um einen disstrack
und ein du bist unter anderem da drin
bei interesse höher ist die mal an es
gab probleme schon angeschaut auch so
erhält man auch geschrieben und ob ich
schon angeschaut habe ja ich hab's mir
gerne angeschaut und ich muss sagen ich
bin noch nicht ganz durch aber mit ein
bisschen enttäuscht nicht schon
[Musik]
koalas gemacht das war es jetzt ja die
bio verboten ich bin ehrlich zu dir wenn
du mir schon schreibst ist krasser
display kommt dann kommt und ich auch
drin
dann geht auch davon aus dass nicht nur
eine leyen gegen mich ist sondern
vielleicht auch mal eine ganze strophe
war jetzt habe ich ja also das einzige
was jetzt auf mich bezogen war ja dieses
macht klick bild und verarscht die leute
also ich bin mal gespannt was noch so
von mir kommt und da hat mich auf jeden
fall super nehmen das alles mit humor
ich meine es ja auch nicht 100 prozent
ernst was ich jetzt sage ist viel
lustiger typ unterhält die leute
deswegen gibt es von mir hier auf wo ich
bin auf meinem zweikanal deswegen gibt
es von mir hier auch einen daumen nach
oben und mehr kann ich dazu eigentlich
gar nicht sagen
ich hoffe dass wieder hat euch gefallen
morgen 19 uhr gibt es das nächste video
auf einem kanal jeden tag 19 uhr
deswegen abonniert den kanal aktiviert
die glocke und folgen auf instagram da
ist sich alex wie wir sehen uns morgen
wieder haut rein